hello there hello there fortnite and
Star Wars have a crossover in game for
the next three weeks with tons of new
abilities it's time to jump back in and
bust some myths like this one is it
possible to use the force on those
harmless Sky jellies that float around
the island well here we go and
okay I was not expecting that myth
confirmed weakened Yates guy jellies
they go so far they despawn Canon
lightsaber block the attack on Titan
Thunder spear attack let's try it
hell yes it can it stops IT midair as
long as you get away from the blast
radius as quickly as possible myth
confirmed each of these three
lightsabers relates to three different
abilities but which sword in which
trading makes you quicker I lined up
three of my loser friends and asked them
to run on my command on both occasions
all three versions were identical no one
has the advantage in this they're all
the same when we visit one of the Jedi
and Sith icons on the map we are rifted
away to learn the basics of the force is
it possible for another person to run
through that open Rift when a player
activates it we all lined up ready and
the moment it opened we sprinted and now
every time we are struck back bounced
back myth busted and for some reason
this glitch happened look at this
monstrosity
we did manage to get to the rift but
it's not possible to use double busted
it's impossible to eliminate someone
when they are traveling through the
force Rift an easy one I got help in for
this one this is my firing squad as soon
as he then it into the void we fired
it's a total no the player is completely
immune the moment they activate the
final text prompt and for good measure
they were shot on the way out and
surprisingly the immune period is longer
than I thought but ultimately it does
run out what about if we stick them with
the spear attack before they Venture in
because there's a timer before that
explodes well it's still no totally
immune during the entire animation so
myth confirmed myth we can use a Sith
Force throw ability to weaponize
vehicles around us this is too good to
be true I got a couple of cars in front
I'm aiming for that Tower there let's do
this
oh wow which means you could likely do
way over 300 damage in just one shot of
this depending on your aim so all three
abilities can move vehicles but can we
Propel ourselves with the force by
standing on a vehicle I first tried this
by standing on the back seats of this
type of vehicle and sadly force
abilities do absolutely nothing but
that's not the end by precariously
standing on the roof or the back but not
actually in the vehicle small movements
are possible but they don't seem very
controllable and don't go very far and
there's a chance the car you're using
will totally despawn like this
weird yet if everything is set up
correctly with Force push you can do
this
Lobby all alone and I still died first
myth confirmed though
[Music]
can we block a kinetic Blade with a
lightsaber
we sure can and seven of them in fact
before our block is broken so if we can
block the kinetic blade we can block the
kinetic R right well let's see
and nope myth busted we cannot block
fast moving purple ore with a neon
glowing stick I took 150 damage
can fall damage be negated by a second
jump that we get from holding a
lightsaber easy test and yes a
well-timed second jump prevents fall
damage but what about a badly timed
second jump for this one I double jumped
so high in the air that I must take fall
damage
but no I was totally fine myth confirmed
any kind of double jump with a saber
from any height prevents fall damage but
what if we are high up and don't have a
lightsaber to rely on can a teammate on
the ground use the force to protect them
from Fall damage up first is Anakin's
pull ability
it works and you've got to admit this
looks pretty damn awesome
next up is Obi-Wan's push ability to
save a friend this one is much less epic
but much more reliable so myth confirmed
it's slightly more Epic from the
perspective of the person being saved
we also tried the first throw and yeah
that's not really Gonna Save anyone
anytime soon so so that one's
technically mid-lusted can a lightsaber
block a direct headshot from a heavy
sniper and not what I expected
myth confirmed but what about a second
bullet the second one breaks The Stance
which means if you fire three times
quickly you'll obliterate them so myth
confirmed a lightsaber can block two
heavy Snipes consecutively is it
possible to hide inside one of the
character Holograms I had high hopes for
this idea to hide in plain sight as
someone comes to claim a sword but look
at this the Holograms are way taller
than any of our Loopers and even wearing
the right skin just doesn't line up I
don't think anyone's falling for this
but you never know anyway myth busted as
we all know Midas can change any weapon
he holds into gold in a myth chaser
video last year we could even turn Vader
saber gold let's see what happens this
time around
oh yikes no not anymore Midas has lost
that ability how about the new Mythic
Blaster instead and it's another fail
sadly Midas no longer changes mythics
into gold it's just standard weapons
speaking of gold do you still collect
those crowns for winning each game
here's the myth can we move winning
crowns using our abilities maybe to
force pull it closer to you so you can
get it before a friend takes it well
don't give it much thought because it
doesn't work totally a shame myth busted
but wait let's turn that frown upside
down can we move a reboot card using the
force check it out yeah a new way to
troll your friends oh maybe you're a
good guy and you push the card to safety
or pull it towards you to save a few
seconds anyway myth confirmed we can
move reboot cards here's another myth
can we throw gas canisters with the
force first up is force throw and to my
surprise it actually ignites the gas
canister so when it's thrown it becomes
a perfect video game bomb and I also
tried this with Force pull and yes it
ignites the fuel and Kaboom so could we
do that when stood on top of it well
sadly this is another busted myth the
canister will not move with Penny's fat
butt on it so you'd need a teammate to
make this work myth busted myth The
Shield bubble is completely impenetrable
to any of the false abilities quick one
to test here's the bubble can we get the
person inside and no not with the force
throw ability but look how easy it is to
get them outside of the bubble with both
boss pull and force push so we gotta say
myth busted oh quick thought is it
possible to hit ourselves with fast
throw for this one I stared at the sky
and tried to hit myself with the rocks
that came crashing back down to earth I
thought it was a good idea but no
Friendly Fire here myth busted myth is
it possible to redirect something which
has been forced thrown at you this would
be totally useful for that time the ore
hit me earlier to set this one up we
used a car and gave 1 play at The High
Ground could they redirect the vehicle
and to my surprise yes and easily yes so
this got me thinking if you've watched
my myth videos in the past you know I
quite like setting the world random
ridiculous world records from stacking
upgrade benches to making trucks fly
with a saw blade and here's a new one
how many times can we juggle a vehicle
without it hitting the floor using the
force go and have a guess the setup was
to slightly lift the car off the ground
and then simply Force push it as
vertically as possible it was tense and
in the end we managed 10 key prps before
the storm interrupted us so I challenge
you can you break my ridiculous world
record it's good to be back playing
fortnite again thanks to you if you've
used cold out of Mario whilst I was away
feeling sorry for myself but I'm back
now and I'm slowly going through my
messages and thanking people personally
like these guys here thank you for that
it's been a pleasure hopefully this was
fun see you next time